bonjour et bienvenue pour ce quatrième
cours de paléontologie des vertébrés
donc la dernière fois nous avions vu
l'origine des amniotes et délices
amphibiens donc les amphibiens moderne
et nous nous étions quittés sur une mise
en garde envers ces deux sites retail
l'évolution de notre homme et aubeterre
aux aurait des airs isis dotcom deux
sites qui proposent des images très
jolie de squelettes et des
reconstitutions très jolie de reptiles
et de dinosaures et d'opter rose en tout
genre mais qui sont souvent trop utilisé
sans vraiment faire attention à l'heure
à leur précision donc voilà je
recommence en par cette mise en garde et
on passe tout de suite
soro psid donc la dernière fois nous
avions vu que les amniotes était composé
de deux branches principales la première
menant au synap side la seconde menant
au sort oxydes donc aujourd'hui on va se
focaliser sur les sort oxydes alors
laisse aux robes si tu sais ce qu'on
appelle les reptiles en général et je
vous avais expliqué durant le dernier
cours que y'a pas finalement c'est un
groupe qui est assez hétérogène en soit
c'est un groupe qui est très diversifiée
déjà et qui va être d'autant plus dit
encore plus diversifiée qu'il ne l'est
aujourd'hui au mésozoïque et c'est un
groupe qui a des racines très ancienne
jusqu'au jusqu'au début du carbonifère
donc trouver des caractères qui sont
soit partagé par tous les sauts robes
site c'est quasiment impossible
et certainement pas la fenestration
temporal donc les ce qu'ont les fausses
temporal tels que je vous les avez
expliqué la dernière fois puisque
primitivement ils sont tous en abside et
après ça va partir un peu dans tous les
sens chez les sauts au pit donc il n'y a
pas vraiment de fenêtres temporal qu'ils
soient partagés par tous les sorts
oxydes donc les il ya quelques
caractères qui sont généraux au sort ou
psid bazot mais qui vont avoir vite
tendance à disparaître ou être modifié
donc le premier c'est la présence d'un
faux ramène suborbital donc ce qu'on
appelle aussi des fois le foramen soro
psid donc c'était un petit foramen
qu'ils se trouvent
entre le palais et les cte opté rigaud
ide et chez lady abside ce forum n va
devenir carrément une fenêtre en fait
dans le palais et on le retrouve chez
les paré azor comme cet exemple ici un
parent et azor du permis à d'afrique du
sud et on retrouve aussi un foramen
comme ça chez certaines tortues moderne
donc c'est ça fait partie des caractères
on va dire les plus les plus faciles à
suivre chez les soeurs opsines mais
c'est pas tout les sauropodes site
qu'ils ont hélas chez les taureaux
piscine généralement les danses ont dit
accro donc au moins primitivement elles
sont accros d'hondt
c'est à dire qu'elles sont juste posé
sur le sommet de la mâchoire et cette
morphologie on l'opposent aux dents
tecau dont tu qu'on retrouve par exemple
chez les synapses id ou du moins chez
les terres apside chez qui vous voyez il
y a une une racine alors que les dents
accroc donc n'ont pas de racines mais
c'est pareil on va voir que chez les
soeurs oxydes tout ça ça va changer
les sauropodes side ont tous un seul et
unique condyle occipital convexe c'est
pas un caractère qui est propre
spécifiquement sur oxyde puisqu'on le
trouve aussi chez les pélico zor et
l'été rapide mais disons que si vous
vous si vous êtes face à un crâne et que
ce crâne 1-1 qu'on dit aux xi pital
convexe vous avez une bonne probabilité
que ce soit le crâne d'un toro-piscine
en tout cas c'est sur le conte le conte
dilettant comex ça risque pas d'être
celui d'un amphibien donc à partir de là
vous identifier le conduit les occitanes
vous essayer d'identifier les fausses
temporal s'il y en a et normalement avec
ça vous devriez en combiné en combinant
les deux et en regardant aussi un peu la
dentition vous devriez arriver à dire si
vous êtes en train de regarder un crâne
de soro psid ou pas et le dernier
caractère mais qui est un caractère qui
ne fossilise pas c'est la présence des
cayes de kératine
ces écailles de kératine qui sont
généralisés a à peu près tous les
reptiles c'est assez rare qui est des
reptiles qui est pas des cayes
exception faite des oiseaux encore que
les oiseaux ont des écailles sur leurs
pieds mais les oiseaux ont des plumes
mais on sait maintenant que développe
mentalement ses plumes sont des écailles
modifié donc il ya pas trop de doutes
sur le fait qu'on peut
les plumes des écailles modifié
aujourd'hui en brio logiquement c'est la
même structure et le développement de
ces écailles et on le sait aussi de
parler les plumes des pieds des oiseaux
c'est les plumes des pieds des oiseaux
pour les oiseaux qui ont des plumes sur
les pieds sont les équivalents des
écailles sur les pieds des oiseaux qui
n'ont pas de plumes sur les pieds donc
donc on sait que la structure plume et
kayes est interchangeable chez les
oiseaux modernes
donc il ya pas trop de pas trop de
doutes sur le fait que les écailles sont
enfin que les plus le son des écailles
modifié mais à part ça on n'a pas
vraiment de caractère de trait qui soit
typique vraiment des soro psid donc ça
rend l'identification au moins au moins
identifié quelque chose comme étant à
soro psid c'est pas facile mais après
les groupes de soro psid à l'intérieur
sont deux à l'intérieur des sons oxydes
les grandes familles sont relativement
faciles à identifier par contre donc on
va commencer d'abord par les familles de
ce site qui ont un crâne en abside donc
rappelez vous je ne fais pas de
classification phylogénétique à ce
niveau là donc je vais juste parler des
espèces qui ont un gradin apside ou plus
ou moins une abside avec ou avec une
toute petite fosse temporal key qu'on
peut relativement ignoré les absides
j'en ai parlé la dernière fois enfin
j'ai parlé des paras reptiles la plupart
de ce qu'on appelait autrefois des
annappes sida donc le groupe d des
espèces avec le crâne
annappes side faisait part font partie
maintenant du clad départ à reptiles et
les paras reptiles c'est le merdier j'en
ai déjà parlé la dernière fois donc on
va pas je vais pas me rées est allé là
dessus donc les adapte side ils n'ont
pas de fenêtre temporal bon déjà c'est
une manière de reconnaître le crâne
d'une espèce de déterminer si elle
appartient à l'un des groupes dont je
vais vous parler maintenant ans donc ils
n'ont pas de fenêtre temporelle l'un des
groupes d'annappes cibler plus
facilement identifiable scellé par
ayasse d'or parce que les pareil azor
ils ont c'est énorme expansion
ici à l'arrière du crâne au niveau de la
joue donc pareil alors ça veut dire
reptiles ajout pareilles à celles ajouts
donc c'est reptiles ajout est la raison
pour laquelle il s'appellerait petit la
joue c'est parce que l'eau squadra taux
du gal est énorme et rectangulaire vous
voyez ici
donc ça fait une grande grande grandes
arcades jus galles comme vous pouvez
voir ici on a aussi une petite une
petite collerette à l'arrière du crâne
qui est présent chez les pareil azor pas
aussi développés évidemment que chez
tricératops 1 mais il ya quand même une
petite collerette à l'arrière et vous
avez généralement des bosses ou des
cornes un peu partout sur la surface du
crâne dont vous avez des bosses sur le
crâne à l'arrière du crâne mais aussi
sur la mandibule comme vous pouvez voir
ici sur l'os angulaire ça c'est très
caractéristique des pareils azor de la
beauce angulaire vous avez aussi un
crâne qui est qui et plein de petits
trous alors pour cette raison il ya des
gens qui ont proposé que les que c'était
comme les crocodiles et qui vivait dans
l'eau mais bon c'est très discutée
puisque les par hasard ce sont des gros
herbivores comme indiqué par leurs dents
voyez que les dents elles sont en forme
de feuille avec des petits denticules ça
ressemble beaucoup à des dents d'iguane
et les iguanes sont herbivores donc les
dames pareil azor indique plutôt un
régime herbivores et on voit pas trop
pourquoi
pourquoi le crâne été perforés comme ça
où on sait pas trop les les analyses
géochimiques semble indiquer que les
parias sort ou au moins une bonne partie
des paris hasardeux vivait plutôt à
l'extérieur de l'eau donc donc donc
affaire à suivre
affaire à suivre et les parts et hazard
sont typiques du permien moyens et
supérieurs on les trouve pas avant et on
les trouve plus après ils s'éteignent la
crise permien trias
on les retrouvera plus après il ya
beaucoup de gens qui pensaient que les
pareil azor été les ancêtres des tortues
parce que les pareil azor ils ont des
îles ondes et ostéo derme sur le dos
donc les au départ et azor du permis à
moyen/long une rangée d'ostéo derme
seulement de chaque côté de la colonne
vertébrale
par contre les pareil azor du permis un
supérieur
ils ont des ostéo d'herbe sur tout le
corps voire même une armure complète et
du coup les gens pensaient que vu qu'ils
avaient le crâne apside et une armure
complète ça allait évoluer en tortue
le fait est que cette armure n'a rien à
voir avec l'armure des tortues comme on
le verra après c'est juste de la peau si
fier c'est pas une carapace de tortue la
carapace de tortue c'est la cage
thoracique qui forment la carapace des
tortues et on va voir comment
mais là c'est pas du tout la cage
thoracique qui forment la carapace chez
les paré azor donc c'est une évolution
convergente vous avez la famille des
pros colo fono id alors ça c'est pour
peut-être une famille dont vous n'avez
jamais entendu parler mais c'est une
famille qui est très abondante en
afrique du sud dans le karoo ce sont des
petits animaux herbivores des petits
reptiles herbivores vous voyez crâne
annappes side on dit qu'ils sont
herbivores parce que vous voyez que les
dents ici sont très étendues
latéralement donc il ya une surface
mastic à trice s il y as surface mastic
attristée que la nourriture était plutôt
dur dur à à digérer et l'a dit donc il
fallait une digestion avant la gestion
et c'est généralement 7 est généralement
il s'agit de fibres végétales en plus
vous avez une certaine hétéro non si
vous avez des dents qu'il est dans près
maxillaire sont différentes des dents du
maxillaire vous avez en gros des
incisives et en gros des molaires même
si c'est même si évidemment faut mettre
des guillemets à tous aller les
incisives et les molaires c'est vraiment
des trucs de mammifères mais bref
donc là vous avez une dentition donc qui
est plutôt indicatrices d'un régime
herbivores donc ça c'est un premier
caractère qui permet d'identifier les
pros colophane aux ide avec des dents
qui sont ce qu'on appelle gonfo d'ordre
c'est à dire plutôt élargi et pas
herbivores comme chez les paré azor où
elles sont en forme de dandy guad là
c'est vraiment des dents élargit un peu
comme un peu comme les mammifères quand
même avec des belles facettes qui
indique qu'ils devaient marcher leur
nourriture les pros call of honor id
ils ont aussi la particularité au moins
pour ceux du trias
enfin pour les plus les formes les plus
dérivé du trias d'avoir des grandes
cornes
un peu comme les pareil azor une fois de
plus donc des grandes cornes jus galles
donc le quadra taux du gal pareil et
étendu latéralement effet cette espèce
de grandes cornes mais ça fait pas eu un
gros coup de râteau du gal carré comme
celle et paris alors c'est plus
rectangulaire bon les pros colo fono ide
sont aussi beaucoup plus petit que les
parias szohr les paradors est
généralement des grosses b
violent avec quelques exceptions alors
que les pros colophon nos idées c'est
enfin les parts et azor cd grosse vache
quoi et les pros colo fono id c'est
plutôt des plus c'est vraiment des
animaux de la taille d'un très gros
lapin on va dire d'un gros lièvre
voilà mais évidemment c'est pas tous ces
pas tous les pros call of you know it
qu'ils n'ont par exemple owen et à
vouvoyer n'ont pas cette expansion jug
alors quand on n'a pas ça qu'est ce
qu'on fait on regarde le foramen pinéale
s'il est immense généralement c'est
qu'on regarde à un proco l'aumônerie
delà il est enfin il est pas si gros que
ça mais comparé la taille du crâne il
est immense et on regarde les yeux les
orbites là vous avez l'orbité ici et
tout ça là à l'arrière c'est pas l'oeil
c'est une expansion de leurs beats qui
devait servir de point la tâche aux
muscles mastic ateurs donc le crâne est
en abside mais ils ont compensé avec
leurs beats et je sais qu'il va y avoir
des commentaires sur ce que je vais me
dire parce que des fois quand je dis
orbite les gens comprennent orbite
donc il compense avec laure bits
je m'égare bref ils ont compensé avec
laure bits et chez wayne et à vous voyez
il ya un très gros oeil ici et à
l'arrière de l'oeil vous voyez cette
petite encoche ici c'est le début en
fait de ce qu'on voit ici chez pro
colophon donc pour que nos fonds et plus
dérivés que wayne états et donc ils sont
très très utilisé aussi pour la datation
on verra que on verra quand ils sont
très utilisés en biostratigraphie
notamment mais aux eaux russes et les
maisons au rider alors ce sont des
petits reptiles du permien du permis à
inférieur très célèbre puisque ça a été
une des premières preuves fossiles
avancé de la dérive des continents donc
alfred wegener à utiliser le fait qu'on
trouvait des maisons au rider de part et
d'autre de l'océan atlantique en afrique
et en amérique du sud pour faire
l'hypothèse que l'amérique du sud et
l'afrique pour soutenir l'hypothèse que
l'amérique du sud et l'afrique étaient
autrefois connectés hypothèse qui a été
confirmée ensuite par la découverte de
plein d'autres fossiles donc des gloss
des feuilles de glossop terrisse par
exemple
on a trouvé des synodes ont aussi de
part et d'autre des mêmes continents on
trouve des synodes honte en had donc tri
naxos dont par exemple le genre tri
naxos dont se trouve à la fois en
afrique en antarctique et en inde
de même que le genre liste rose aux
russes ici représentée en rouge qu'on
trouve en afrique en arctique et en inde
si nos gonds hiatus qu'on retrouve en
afrique et en amérique du sud dont vous
voyez qu'il ya et pro colophon enfin les
pros colo fono idées on les retrouve
même jusqu'en australie donc pas
seulement on hamm est en afrique du sud
on y retrouve en antarctique est aussi
en australie
donc il ya beaucoup de faux cils comme
ça qu'ils soutiennent que le gondwana
donc l'ensemble des continents du sud
étaient réunis tous ensemble il y à 260
millions d'années mais le premier
fossile à avoir mis la puce à l'oreille
d'un chercheur ça a été mais autorise
donc mais aux eaux russes il est très
facilement reconnaissable voyez que
c'est pas un gros fossiles c'est un
petit reptile plutôt gracile mais il n'y
a qu'une seule chose qui ait pas gracile
dans son autonomie et ce sont ces côtes
ses côtes sont absolument gigantesque et
on dit qu'elles sont pas qui est aux tic
c'est à dire qu'elles sont très
fortement très épaisse et on pourrait
même dire pâquis ostéo sclérotique dans
le sens où elles sont aussi très dense
et ça c'est pour c'est parce qu'elles
servent de ballasts pour maintenir
l'animal au fond de l'eau parce que mes
aux eaux russes est un petit animal
nageurs sa queue est aplati elle est
aplati comme une queue de crocodile ses
membres vous voyez sont plutôt sont pas
très aussi sont pas sont pas très
développée donc les doigts notamment
sont pas très aussi fier et puis là le
museau voyez un très long museau très
crocodiliens avec des toutes petites
dents très fine qui devait servir à
filtrer l'eau on a d'ailleurs retrouvé
des maisons aux russes avec le contenu
stomacal qui contenait des des petits
crustacés des verts enfin des choses
comme ça donc c'était un animal qui se
nourrissait de petits invertébrés dans
l'eau et à l'époque en afrique du sud il
vivait dans une espèce de mer intérieure
où se trouvait le caroux donc au début
du permien en fait le caroux c'était mer
intérieure et puis qui sait au fur et à
mesure à sécher qui est devenu une
grande plaine d'inondations enfin plus
ou moins marécageuse par endroits
évidemment avec plus ou moins de rivière
mais en général c'était une grande
plaine d'inondations un grand bassin
sédimentaire quoi intracontinentale les
caps taurine idée donc encore un groupe
dont on n'entend pas tant que ça parlait
en général les cape town irigny décès
alors ils sont pas inclus dans les paras
reptiles du moins quand on regarde les
phylogénie ils sont généralement exclues
des paras reptiles mais de manière
générale ils ont un crâne qui ressemble
beaucoup à celui des parts est il donc
annappes side qui a des îles ont des
petites perforations sur la surface du
crâne comme les pareil azor ils sont
herbivores donc comme les pareil azor et
les propos l'ophone idée mais encore
avec une dentition différentes donc les
pareil azor avait les dents en forme de
feuille les pros colo faune idée avait
des dents élargie et bien eux ils ont
plein de petites dents des petites dents
qui sont toutes simples juste un bâton
quoi mais ils en ont plein répartis sur
plusieurs rangées et qui se renouvelle
de l'intérieur vers l'extérieur comme
chez les requins donc en fait vous avez
déranger dentaire qui se renouvellent
qui se renouvelle perpétuellement et qui
servent en fait à deux surfaces pour
broyer la nourriture donc les ça c'est
très très typique des caps taurine idée
d'avoir ces sept heures ce
renouvellement dentaire donc pour
l'instant les capteurs une idée ont
surtout été trouvé dans l'hémisphère
nord mais on en a en afrique notamment
dans le permis à du niger découvert
découvert si je me rappelle bien
justement par l'équipe de sébastien
steyer enfin l'équipe dont ceux de
sébastien steyer faisait partie quand il
fouillait au niger donc c'est une très
belle découverte et en afrique du sud on
a des caps torigni rhino morph
intéressant on va dire dans le sens où
est justement ils n'ont pas toutes ces
spécialisations ils ont ils ont un crâne
plutôt lisse vous voyez aussi que les
capteurs une idée ils ont un
ils ont un oeil une orbite relativement
petit alors que la l'orbité relativement
grande et on a une seule rangée dentaire
chez ce capteur une idée là
donc la chose qui rattache soro rictus
cap torino mort d'afrique du sud au cap
taurine idées comme aura 10 aux russes
bah c'est la dentition qui est hétéro
dont vous voyez que là vous avez des
genres comme avec un peu pro colo faut
ni les colonisés vous avez des genres
d'incisives suivi de dents molères et là
c'est pareil vous avez des dents à
sisyphe qui sont plus grosses que les
dangers galles en fait donc c'est un peu
la seule chose qui le rattache avec
d'autres détails anatomiques qui sont un
peu trop un peu trop pointu pour que je
les lis tu ici mais en tout cas voilà on
a probablement une
'l'indice d'une origine gondwana n 2 dé
cape thorigne mort avec soro rictus
parce que c'est probablement l'un des
plus primitifs
ceci étant dit comme je les dis la
distribution des caps torino morphée
largement largement plus tôt dans les
dans l'hémisphère nord donc c'est s'est
fortement à débattre mais en tout cas
voilà il a l'air beaucoup plus primitif
que d'autres capteurs une idée que les
capteurs une idée et les capteurs une
idée donc ils trouvent leur origine au
carbone y faire et il perdure jusqu'à
l'extinction permien trias et maintenant
on passe aux aux animaux qui ont un
crâne dit abside donc le crâne diab site
vous le savez déjà c'est le crâne qui a
deux fosses temporal donc il y en a une
sur le côté et il y en a une sur le
dessus donc ça c'est le caractère le
plus évident dédié abside après il ya
d'autres caractères notamment le fait
que le foramen dit abside de via une
fenêtre qu'on appelle la fenêtre
suborbital donc elle est toujours quand
entre le palais électo pts et rigaud id
donc on est bien sûr que ces mêmes trous
mais il est juste beaucoup plus gros et
chez lady abside on a en gros on a en
gros le quatrième doigt qui est beaucoup
plus long que les autres doigts alors
les doigts le quatrième doigt était déjà
le plus long de tous les doigts chez les
ch et les amiotte c'était déjà le cas
chez les amis note par contre ça comparé
par exemple là ça doit être un amphibien
j'imagine donc c'est déjà le plus long
chez les amniotes mais par contre
il est encore plus long chez les ch et
les dioxydes parce que le quatrième
métatarse et super lent donc le
quatrième métatarse ici c'est ce que
c'est lorsque vous voyez là il est deux
fois plus long que le premier métatarse
que vous voyez là donc ça c'est donc
c'est ce déséquilibre des proportions
des métatarse c'est typique des dioxydes
et c'est pour ça que quand vous voyez un
lézard sur un mur vous remarqué que le
quatrième douala de son pied il est
quand même vachement plus long que les
que les autres doigts c'est dieu à ça
c'est c'est un caractère qu'ils ont
hérité de leurs ancêtres
l'ancêtre commun à tous les dioxydes
donc lady abside apparaissent dès la fin
du carbonifère en amérique du nord
et ici j'ai choisi de vous représenter
young jin a dû du permis et parce qu'il
vient d'afrique du sud mais qu'il est
assez représentatif on va dire de la
morphologie ancestrale des dioxydes à
part pour un petit détail c'est que le
lacrymal normalement chez les ch et 10
abside du carbonifère le lacrymal peut
contribuer en fait à la fin 76 jusqu'à
la narine
c'est la seule différence et puisqu'on
parle des dix abside on va parler du cas
particulier des kélonia donc les quais
le lien qui est la grande famille des
tortues et on va parler notamment de
notes aux orris africanus qui est l'un
des plus anciens kélonia donc les enfin
du moins à des plus en une des plus
anciennes espèces qu'on rattache au
kélonia même si on est encore un peu
frileux à appeler nos taurus à kélonia
alors déjà ce qu'il faut savoir avec les
tortues d'aujourd'hui donc c'est
qu'elles ont à crâne un apside mais le
problème c'est qu'on a fait des analyses
génétiques sur les tortues et que ces
analyses génétiques ont montré qu'en
fait les tortues c'était des cousines
des crocodiles et des oiseaux donc ce
qu'on appelle les archosaures et les
crocodiles et les oiseaux se sont dédiés
abside donc les tortues en fait elles
ont un ancêtre commun avec des dioxydes
et elles sont même plus proche des
crocodiles que les lézards ne sont
proches des crocodiles
ce qui veut dire que leurs ancêtres il
ya quasiment aucun doute que l'ancêtre
des tortues devait avoir un crâne dit
abside
puisqu'elles sont très profondément leur
origine évolutive et très profondément
enraciné parmi des reptiles qui sont
tous dits apside donc a pas trop de
doutes sur le fait que l'ancêtre des
tortues avait deux fosses temporal le
problème c'est que les tortues moderne
n'en n'ont aucune elles n'ont pas de
fausse temporaire et une auto russe
eh bien il est un peu venu à la
rescousse des paléontologues en dix ans
en dix ans mais si mais si regardez moi
je sais comment les tortues ont perdu
leur fausse temporal donc une auto russe
le voici le voilà c'est cet animal là
alors vu comme ça il n'a pas
spécialement l'air d'une tortue il a il
a quand même une très très longue que
donc c'est pas vraiment typique des
tortues là pas de carapace ses épaules
sont allés à l'extérieur de sa cage
thoracique ce qui n'est pas le cas chez
les tortues les tortues ont les épaules
à l'intérieur de la cage thoracique
c'est bien pour ça qu'elle arrive à
replier leurs bras à l'intérieur de leur
corps de leur carapace
c'est parce que leur leurs épaules sont
à l'intérieur de leur cage thoracique et
leur carapace c'est leur cage thoracique
mais par contre il est il est il nous
montre quand même noter aux russes
comment les la carapace des tortues a
évolué donc sa cage thoracique
elle est comme à défaut d'être
recouverte d'une cas d'être une carapace
elle est quand même relativement
sphérique elle est très courte
comme chez les tortues il ya seulement
qu' il n'y a que 10 vertèbres à
l'intérieur de sa cage thoracique donc
c'est assez proche de ce qu'on trouve
chez les tortues et les côtes sont très
étendues donc elles sont pas encore
fusionné les unes aux autres comme on le
voit chez les tortues moderne chez les
tortues moderne les côtes sont
complètement fusionné les unes aux
autres mais par contre elles sont
suffisamment larges pour recouvrir
complètement la cage thoracique
donc elles sont pas encore fusionné mais
on n'a déjà plus ou moins un état qui
est équivalent fonctionnellement à une
carapace et ça ça un résultat
intéressant c'est que ça donne aux côtes
de noto aux russes une section en forme
de t quand on coupe à l'intérieur
exactement comme chez les tortues
moderne et tortueux modernes ont aussi
une section en forme de t une décôte
avec une section en forme de t quand on
l'est
coupe donc note aux eaux russes pour ça
il avait il était plutôt proche des des
tortues moderne
on sait aussi d'après l'analyse
justement quitte à faire des sections à
l'intérieur on a aussi regardé
l'histologie de des côtes de notes aux
eaux russes est en fait grâce à liszt au
logis on a pu voir que les côtes
n'étaient pas mobile elle n'était pas
capable de s'étendre et de se et de se
replier en fin de la cage thoracique ne
pouvait pas s'étendre avec la
respiration en fait contrairement à ce
qu'on voit chez les lézards les lézards
il respire en étendant et en contractant
leur cage thoracique
on fait un petit peu ça aussi
normalement d'essence et respirer avec
le diaphragme et on se sert aussi de nos
muscles intercostaux pour respirer quand
on a vraiment besoin de prendre beaucoup
d'air les tortues ne peuvent pas faire
ça puisque l on une carapace et bien un
auto russe
on sait grâce aux sections qui ont été
faites dans les côtes de notes aux eaux
russes est bien on sait qu'il n'avait
pas non plus de muscles intercostaux
donc il n'était pas capable d'étendre et
de replier et de contracter la cage
thoracique donc exactement comme une
tortue donc vraiment sa cage thoracique
même si ce n'est pas encore une carapace
fonctionnellement
elle agit déjà comme une carapace donc
c'est donc il ya pas trop de doutes sur
le fait que nos taurus fait partie des
ancêtres enfin de la ligne est
ancestrale qui a donné naissance au
kélonia maintenant le crâne de notes aux
russes ce qui est intéressant c'est que
à l'état adulte le crâne est en abside
par contre à l'état juvénile c'est ce
que vous voyez là vous voyez là l'oeil
est ici vous avez une fausse temporal
haute et une fausse temporal bas ce qui
n'est d'ailleurs pas complètement fermée
par l'os jug à les quadras tôt je gagne
donc ça c'est même plus qu'un caractère
de diab site c'est même un truc qui
évoque les squamates mais on verra ça
après non bref s est présent aussi
d'ailleurs chez certains par arrêt
peut-il donc j'ai pas vraiment parler
parce que j'ai pas non plus tout le
temps du monde
hélas mais ça se trouve chez les uns
chez un petit groupe de parents reptiles
qui s'appelle les milliards est idée
donc voilà on a cette fausse temporal
base qui est légèrement ouverte comme ça
vers le bas et mais il ya quand même une
fausse temporal autres est une fausse
temporal basse clairement identifiable
donc ça c'est très différent des tortues
moderne et il ya aussi le fait qu'on a
des dents ça aussi c'est très différent
des temps modernes qui l ont un bec les
dents d'ailleurs sont conservés à l'état
adulte par contre les fausses temporal
elles sont perdues à l'état adulte
elles sont recouvertes par l'os supra
temporal vous voyez ici et par la
combinaison de ce post orbitaire ce quoi
moselle et jules galles pour la fosse
temporal basse donc ça c'est très
intéressant parce que ça nous montre en
fait si on part du principe que l'on au
génie récapitule la phylogénie bas ça
nous montre comment en fait les kélonia
ont perdu leur fausse temporal si si
l'évolution des quais du crâne des
kélonia s'est passé comme l'ontogénèse
du crâne de notes aux russes alors c'est
probablement l'os supra temporal key est
venu boucher l'info ce temporal
supérieur et c'est probablement là et la
fosse temporal inférieur a été rebouché
par le développement des os qui
l'entouraient donc ça c'est très très
intéressant c'est extrêmement
intéressant et surtout ben le juvénile
de noto aux russes montrent que
primitivement il y avait des fausses
temporal chez les ancêtres des kélonia
ici vous avez encore une fois un corps
de kélonia avec une tête d'eudis abside
donc on a une fois de plus un très très
bon intermédiaire structurale entre 1,10
abside et les kélonia qui ont le crâne
adapted donc et nos toros
alors évidemment vous pourriez vous dire
que le fait de voir ça chez un juvénile
ça prouve pas grand chose puisque c'est
pas conservé à l'état adulte même
maintenant on a aussi un une nouvelle
espèce qui vient d'allemagne qui
s'appelle papou kelly ce qui est plus
tardive que note aux oreilles sonauto
aux russes on le trouve dans le permien
dans le permis à moyen et le début du
permien supérieur alors que pape auquel
ici vient du trias mémé papou kelis
c'est aussi une terre
euh basale un kélonia basale et il a
aussi un crâne dit abside sauf que là on
a des spécimens adultes avec un crâne si
ma psy dit abside donc donc maintenant
c'est confirmé on peut tout à fait dire
que les kélonia sont dédiés abside on
peut pas encore vraiment dire si ce sont
vraiment le groupe frère dé archosaures
il y a un os à l'intérieur de la boîte
crânienne qui s'appelle latéraux ce
phénomène qui semble être un os qu on ne
retrouve que chez les tortues et les
crocodiles
mais c'est très très débattue c'est très
très débattue l'homologie de l'os en
elle-même est débattue la présence de
l'osce évidemment on voi aux dons qu'il
n'allait pas débattue mais par contre
l'homologie de l'os entre les kélonia et
les crocodiles c'est plutôt débattue
donc voilà on a une auto au russe qui
n'a pas encore de bec mais qui a des
dents enfin mais qui a des dents à la
place qui n'a pas encore de carapace
mais qui a des cotes très étendue et
presque sur le point de fusionner et en
forme de t an quand on découpe et qui a
un crâne en abside quand ils les adultes
mais dit ah ben si tu quand il est jeune
donc on a vraiment très très belle
intermédiaire structurale chez cet
animal et on a on a aussi avant que je
passe à la suite mais maintenant on a
découvert et or un coq et lisse et or un
coq et lisse c'est une autre tortue
basale mais qui vient de chine cette
fois encore une fois du trias et 7 et or
un coq et lisse il est assez formidables
parce qu'en fait il
il a exactement le corps de nos taurus
avec le bec en plus donc il ya quelques
dents à l'arrière mais sinon l'avant du
museau n'a quasiment n'a pas de dents et
devait avoir devait porter un bec
donc c'est on peut voir en fait que
l'aider enfin que les proches parents de
nos taurus légèrement plus dérivés que
nos taurus se dirigeait lentement mais
sûrement vers une morphologie de plus en
plus de plus en plus quelle aune yens
donc on a hero un coq ellis après on va
avoir au d'auto kelis aussi de chine qui
va développer le plastron c'est à dire
tous c'est à dire que les gars strahl
îles et côtes ventrale
vont se transformer en carapace aussi et
jusqu'à ce qu'on arrive au stade prog à
nautilis prog a noté ellis chez qui
toutes les cotes sont fusionnés ici vous
pouvez voir les côtes ici qui développe
cette plaque comme chez eux comme chez
renault taurus donc tous et qui sont
toutes fusionner et qui sont fusionnés
en plus avec de la peau est si fier donc
des ostéo derme pour former à carapace
vous pouvez voir ici les épaules
donc la ceinture scapulaire qui est à
l'intérieur de la carapace donc ce qui
permet enfin ce qui permettra aux
tortues futur pas programme auquel il
devait pas encore pour le faire ce qui
permettra aux tortues futur de pouvoir
rentrer leurs membres à l'intérieur de
leur carapace et leur tête à l'intérieur
de leur carapace et vous avez aussi
évidemment un plastron et vous avez un
bec donc pour gagner kelis c'est
vraiment le premier truc qu'on peut
réellement appeler une tortue ceci dit
il est encore différent des tortues
moderne jabeur ya plein de gens qui
veulent dire que parce qu'on n'avait
progrès au calice au trias alors les
tortues date du trias non il a encore
des différences avec les tortues
modernes notamment des petites cornes à
l'arrière du crâne qu'on a pu chez les
tortues moderne il ya des dents sur le
palais donc les dents ont été perdus au
niveau du bec mais il ya toujours des
dents sur le palais et ses dents ont été
perdus chez les tortues moderne donner
ici vous pouvez voir le fenêtre soro
psid d'ailleurs donc qui relie l'est qui
renie qui relie encore une fois progrès
donc ellis au dioxyde et au sort obs il
en général et vous avez et vous avez sur
la queue de programmes auxquels il ya
une espèce de grosse masse d'armes qu'on
retrouve chez ou qu'une tortue moderne
donc
donc il ne faut pas non plus résumé pour
organique et enfin faut pas non plus
dire sous prétexte que pro gano kelis a
déjà le plan d'organisation générale
d'une tortue que les tortues n'ont pas
évolué depuis le trias non c'est juste
que les tortues ont un plan
d'organisation qui est très très
reconnaissable qui est très très
stéréotypé et après il ya quand même eu
des changements autour de ce plan
d'organisation
c'est comme dire
que les oiseaux sont aussi les fossiles
vivants parce que les oiseaux c'est un
pas trop changé depuis le crétacé depuis
le crétacé un oiseau stan oiseaux ça le
même plan d'organisation stéréotypé mais
c'est pas pour autant que ces des
fossiles vivants
voilà vous appelleriez pas un oiseau un
fossile vivant alors pourquoi une tortue
quoi et les tortues elle même on peut
les diviser en deux groupes donc comme
je les dis pour garneau kelis ne pouvait
pas rentrer la tête dans sa carapace
mais à partir du moment où les tortues
vont pouvoir rentrer la tête dans leur
carapace
elles vont le faire de deux façons
différentes qui permet de distinguer
deux grand clac de grands groupes qui
sont morphologiquement cohérent et qui
sont phylogénétiquement cohérent aussi
donc ce sont deux donc c'est non
seulement c'est utile mais en plus c'est
vrai voilà donc les c2 différence est
mince et les tortues qui vont rentrer la
tête par le côté qu'on appelle les
pleureuses dire ici sur la gauche et les
tortues qui vont entrer la tête vers
l'arrière qu'on appelle les crypto dire
les pleureuses d'hier ont généralement
un très très long cou et puis évidemment
elles vont avoir des adaptations des
vertèbres pour pouvoir tourner la tête
de façon extrême et on sait grâce à leur
registre fossile qu'elles sont
originaires du gondwana quelque part
durant le mésozoïque probablement durant
le le jurassique
donc on en retrouve beaucoup notamment
en afrique et en amérique du sud et les
crypto dire qu'ils rentrent leur tête
donc vers l'arrière et bien pour pouvoir
tirer leur tête vers l'arrière elles
vont avoir une grosse crête sur la tête
concrètes sagittale sur laquelle de gros
muscles
ici vous pouvez voir vont être inséré
qui vont lui permettre de tirer la tête
vers l'arrière dans sa carapace
donc c'est les deux grands groupes de
tortue tête sur le côté pleuraux dire
donc l'euro cotait dire articulations et
tête vers l'arrière crypto dire donc
crypto comme superman dire comme
l'articulation
un autre groupe de diab steed et
certainement le plus grand groupe de dix
abside moderne c'est celui des les
pizzerias donc c'est là que vous avez
trouvé les lézards les serpents et le
tuatara donc c'est l'epide aux orres se
sont dédits abside qui vont être plutôt
caractérisée par des traits de leur
anatomie post crânienne donc des traits
du squelette plus que des traits plus
que des traits du crâne
donc le premier de ces caractères ça va
être la présence d'une fausse thyroïde
dans le bassin donc une espèce de
grandes fenêtres à l'intérieur du bassin
qui allège enfin qui rend le bassin
finalement assez assez léger on s'est
même si je ne suis pas complètement sûr
de quoi sert cette fausse thyroïde mais
en tout cas c'est voilà c est un
caractère notable la fusion des deux os
des chevilles donc le l'astragale et le
cac le calcanéum donc il ya plus qu'une
ce cas seul os qui fait l'articulation
entre le pied et le tibia et aussi la
présence je crois que c'est le caractère
le plus notable la présence d'un
cinquième métatarse qui est coût des
coudes et ou en forme de crochets donc
c'est ce qu'on voit ici donc vous
regardez là vous avez le quatrième doigt
qui est très très long vous rappeler de
ça c'est typique de tous les dix abside
et si en plus vous avez le cinquième
métatarse
c'est à dire l'os qui accroche le
cinquième doigt au reste du pied ce
cinquième hausse à facettes au cela s'il
est en forme de coude comme ça s'il est
plié eh bien vous êtes en train de
regarder à l'epide aux orres ça donne un
peu la pression en fait que le cinquième
doit être opposable au lieu d'être le
pouce en fait c'est le petit doigt qui
est opposable
donc c'est ce que vous voyez par exemple
chez les ch et les lézards encore une
fois donc vous avez le quatrième doigt
et en plus chez les lézard des murailles
vous allez voir que le cinquième doigt
qui vient juste après il a il n'est pas
aligné avec les autres en fait il est
légèrement décalé et bien ça c'est à
cause de cette morphologie du cinquième
métatarse coude et donc ça fait des
lézardes et lépide aux orres au sein des
dioxydes
donc cette morphologie on la retrouve
depuis un petit animal qui s'appelle et
les os us qui vient du permien d'afrique
du sud
donc c'est certainement le plus ancien
l'epide aux orres vous avez encore une
fois lyon ghana qui n'est pas seulement
la dioxine mais qui est aussi à l'epide
aux ors et vous avez ici le ce fait nos
dons donc le ce fait nos dons qu'il ya
des dioxydes lépi dozos rien les plus
banales et qui vit encore aujourd'hui
puisqu'il s'agit du toit tara donc ce
fait nos dons toi ta race et c'est la
même chose c'est le groupe des racques
au cfaa lia et se sert un cos faya ils
sont présents depuis au moins le trias
ils ont été très diversifiées au
mésozoïque mais aujourd'hui il n'existe
plus que le tuatara qui vit en nouvelle
zélande et qui est reconnaissable par
ses incisives qui sont fusionnés auprès
maxillaire et qui lui donne un peu ses
dents de lapin que vous voyez là il est
aussi reconnaissable parce que c'est le
seul dit abside moderne chez qui la
morphologie dioxyde est absolument
inaltérée donc vous voyez toujours les
deux fosses temporal on verra que chez
les autres les pi 2 or donc chez les
autres dit abside moderne en fait la
morphologie est altérée on a vu déjà
l'exemple des kélonia chez qui la
morphologie des apps idée complètement
perdu et on va voir que chez les autres
l'epide aux orres les lézards et les et
les serpents cette morphologie dit ah
ben si tu vas être altérée donc là c'est
le seul qui a vraiment les deux fosses
temporal bien complète bien fermé avec
notamment ici le quadra tôt gilles
gallet le jus galles qui ferment
complètement là la barre de qui forment
la barre qui ferme la fenêtre temporelle
inférieur et l'espé naudon enfin les
rats causé fayard ont aussi de une
double rangée dentaire sur les dents du
haut donc ça c'est là c'est les seuls
aussi à voir ça ils ont une double
rangée dentaire au lieu d'avoir une
seule rangée de dents ils en ont deux et
donc en afrique du sud par exemple on
retrouve clevo aux russes mais il ya eu
des rats causé fall absolument partout
on en retrouve à canjuers par exemple en
france
si je ne me trompe pas et on en retrouve
aussi à
à sollenau fans en allemagne donc dans
le mésozoïque dans le jurassique et à
chaque fois on les reconnaît à ce petit
set au spray maxillaire qui est fusionné
aux incisives en fait la classification
des l'épi d'or elle va être basé non pas
sur les fausses temporal parce
qu'évidemment ils sont tous dits à petit
donc on peut pas vraiment se baser sur
les fausses temporel mais va être
surtout basé sur l'insertion dentaire
donc la façon dont les dents sont
insérés dans la mâchoire et sur les
points d'articulation à l'intérieur du
crâne
donc il ya celle et lépide aux orres on
va voir qu'il ya un groupe en
particulier qui s'appelle les squamates
à l'intérieur duquel on va le crâne va
développer de nouvelles articulations
donc on a déjà vu les reins causeur qui
ont le secret maxillaire fusionner avec
les dents et ils ont une dentition
accroc dont ils ont le petit peu
primitif
on va dire pour les europe side nous
allons voir l'essor opté rien les
ichthyosaures rien donc les
ichthyosaures et les les plésiosaures
évidemment ce ne sont pas des l'épi d'or
mais on les place souvent parmi les
lipides aux oraux mort donc donc ça on
verra on les verra quand on parlera des
animaux avec un crade e ri apside mais
sachez que phylogénétiquement les
placerait plutôt du côté des les délais
pi2 or à côté des lipides aux orres dans
ce qu'on appelle les pid aux oraux morph
aider l'épi d'or vrai donc ça va être
les squamates chez qui on aura les là
certes il vient donc les lézards et les
aux fidjiens les des serpents et donc
chez les lézards ce qu'on va avoir c'est
une dentition pleuraux d'hondt avec les
dents qui s'attachent sur le côté de la
mâchoire et non pas sur le dessus de la
mâchoire et chez les officiers on va
avoir dentition qui sera pleuraux d'onde
pour la plupart des dents et teko dont
tous ont dit des fois pseudo tu es
codante pour les pour les serpents qui
auront des grandes des grandes dents qui
envoie du venin donc les les crocs voilà
les crocs des serpents ils vont avoir
une dentition ils vont être plutôt tecau
donc donc ils vont avoir une
une racine mais seulement sur les crocs
les autres dents n'ont pas de nom pas de
racines sont éco dont sont son pleuraux
d'hondt aussi donc commençons par les
souks ou amat donc c'est là qu'on va
avoir les serpents et les lézards et
chez les squamates donc il ya pas mal de
nouvelles de nouveaux caractères qui
apparaissent et il y à déjà la dentition
pleuraux donc donc d'ailleurs si vous
vous rappelez de la sphère de
l'occupante avis le fait qu'il ait des
d'amples euros dont tu as été un
caractère déterminant pour dire qu'il
s'agissait pas du tout d'un oiseau mais
qu'il s'agissait bien d'un lézard en
plus on a trouvé un foramen pinéale ce
qui n'est normalement pas le cacher chez
les archosaures donc
donc voilà la dentition pleuraux d'onde
c'est un caractère qui peut être très
très utile et que que des gens
apparemment oublié alors qu'ils sont
censés être des scientifiques et de et
qu'ils sont censés publié dans des
grandes revues genre nature's donc
rappelez vous de la dentition pleuraux
d'hondt c'est important c'est très
important
alors la dentition et pleuraux d'hondt
sauf chez les mozart mais on verra ça
après du fait de la dentition pleuraux
dompter bien il ya une gouttière à
l'intérieur de la mâchoire dans laquelle
les d'amples euros dont tu sincère donc
il ya une petite petites gouttières sur
l'intérieur de la mâchoire et vous avez
ce qu'on va appeler des joints des
joints kinetic ou des articulations
kinetic à l'intérieur du crâne et chez
les squamates vous en avez normalement
2 la première c'est le joint stripped
hostile hic
ou articulations stripped hostile hic
normalement dans un crâne dans un crâne
de reptiles normalement constitué la
mandibule la tâche de la mandibule
constitue la seule articulation à
l'intérieur du crâne la mandibule
s'articule par rapport au crâne c'est le
seul c'est la seule articulation que
vous voyez qui concerne la tête on va
dire
et si vous vous rappelez il y avait il y
avait chez les lézards kopter et gien il
y avait un joint un joint intracrânien
qui vous permettait à la boîte crânienne
de s'articuler par rapport au palais qui
a été qui a été perdu chez la plupart
des amniotes pas chez tous mais chez la
plupart donc ça ça c'était c'est pour ça
que j'utilise le mot juin articulations
c'est la même chose
bon bref et donc chez les ch et les
squamates vous avez une articulation en
plus donc vous avez toujours le crâne
qui s'articule à la mâchoire par l'os
qui s'appelle le carré donc ça c'est la
condition normale et en plus de ça le
carré lui-même s'articule avec le crâne
ce qui fait que ça crée une double
articulation en fait de la mâchoire
ça permet d'ouvrir la bouche encore plus
grand puisque vous avez un plus une plus
grande une plus grande ampleur de
mouvement grâce au fait que le carré
soit très très long et qu'il s'articule
en plus avec le crâne et c'est pour ça
que la le crâne dit abside est altéré
chez les squamates ce parce que le carré
du coup n'est plus attaché au jus galles
par l'os qui se trouve entre les deux
qui s'appelle le quadra taux du gal et
qui ferment normalement la fosse
temporal inférieur donc comme le carré
doit être libre de bouger pour pouvoir
pour que cette articulation stripped
hostile il soit utile et bien il est
plus attachée aux quadras taux du gal du
coup il ya plus de quadras taux de
galles du tout en fait et du coup la
fosse temporal inférieure est totalement
perdu donc c'est pour ça que je disais
le ch et les squamates la condition
dioxyde est altérée c'est parce qu'on
perd en fait l'articulation c'est parce
qu'on perd en fait le quadra tôt gilles
gallet du coup la fosse temporal
inférieur et en plus de cette
articulation supplémentaires sur le
carré qui s'appelle donc le joint
stripped hostile hic on a un juin mais
aucune éthique c'est à dire à une
articulation juste au dessus de l'oeil
entre le frontal et le pariétal qui
permet à la bouche de souvenirs plus
grande donc la bouche peu souvenirs
s'ouvrir plus grands un peu comme en
fait c'est déjà une prémisse de ce qu'on
va voir chez les serpents ou le crâne
peut complètement se désarticuler pour
permettre de
j'ai des gros des grosses proies en fait
donc c'est déjà ça commence déjà avec
l'ancêtre ans en commun des squamates et
c'est déjà plus ou moins essayer la
condition qu'on voit chez la plupart des
lézards alors que tous et toutes ses
articulations n'existe pas chez le toit
tara c'est pour ça que le toit tara
n'est pas considéré comme un lézard
même si ça ressemble énormément à un
lézard le toit tara n'est pas un lézard
et en plus de ça il n'y a pas de gastes
rallye sur le sur le ventre donc il ya
plus de côtes ventrale chez les squames
hâte
bon ça c'est un caractère voilà où vous
vous le prenez vous le prenez pas vous
en faites ce que vous voulez le plus
ancien possibles candidats pour
l'origine des squamates bien que ce soit
débattue c'est pas l'iguana alors pas
l'iguana il a un très très long
oscar est comme chez les squames at il
est articulé en bas vers la main à la
mandibule comme chez tout le monde
il articule et en os avec le crâne comme
chez les squamates donc il ya un joint
stripped hostile hic
le problème c'est que le pariétal et le
frontal son sont articulés normalement
ils n'ont pas de il n'y a pas de juin
mais aucune éthique
par contre donc s'il s'agit bel et bien
d'un squamates il n'a pas encore tous
les caractères des squamates donc c'est
un squamates extrêmement basale ce qui
va avec son âge trias je me permets je
me suis permis de changer en fait de
corriger parce que je viens de me rendre
compte que je n'avais pas remis à jour
ça en fait ça a changé il ya très il n'y
a pas très longtemps
il ya encore peu de temps il y avait un
doute est-ce que c'était permien trias
j'avais laissé permien est en fait une
publication qui vient de sortir il ya
quelques semaines seulement et qui
confirme que c'est du trias c'est pas du
père bien et j'avais oublié de changer
ça sur ma diapos donc voilà je les
corrige et je mets à jour mon diaporama
au fur et à mesure des découvertes mais
des fois je me rends pas tout de suite
compte que que qu'il ya des choses à
changer donc voilà pas l'iguana plus
anciens possible squamates mais encore
une fois s'est débattue et qui viendrait
du et qui vient du trias du début du
trias d'afrique du sud dont celle et
squamates on a trois grands groupes
modernes
on a les serpents qu'on appelle les aux
fidjiens on a les lézards qu'on appelle
les la sarthe îliens et on a les en fils
miens qui sont tellement anecdotique
tellement peu diversifiée et tellement
introuvable de toute façon que je vais
je vais me retenir d'en parler les ans
fils begnins c'est des lézards qui sont
un peu aulas ils sont un peu au
squamates ce que les cécilien s'auto
sont aux amphibiens
c'est à dire c'est un groupe qui
ressemble qui a vaguement une forme de
verre deux verres de terre qui bon qui
ressemble pour le cou à des serpents vu
qu'ils n'ont pas de bras ni jambes ou
qu'ils ont des tout petits bras
éventuellement mais comme biped par
exemple mais mais voilà ils sont ils
sont assez anecdotique en termes de
diversité
ils sont marrant parce qu'ils ont un
crâne qui est extrêmement massif alors
même que je vais vous dire que la barre
voilà la barre quadras du le quadra taux
du gal était perdue donc globalement le
crâne est plutôt léger c'est d'ailleurs
de là que vient le terme l'epide aux
orres c'est céder les arts léger quoi
parce que le crâne est très allégée du
fait que c'est très aéré on va dire et
donc les ans fils bnia ils reviennent en
arrière là dessus lerhe développe un
crâne supermassifs mais avec les eaux
qu'ils avaient qu'ils avaient c'est à
dire qu'il re le quadra taux de galles
par exemple il revient pas donc ils
improvisent avec ce qu'ils ont c'est
très marrant les ans fils begnins pour
ça et puis ils ont une espèce de alors
il je crois que c'est les seuls
tétrapodes qui ont ça ils ont une grosse
dent médial donc entre les deux pré
maxillaire à l'avant de la bouche ils
ont une grosse dent au milieu mais je
crois que c'est pas tous les ans fils
begnins qui ont ça c'est à vérifier donc
bref les enfants se baignant du coup
j'en parlerai pas trop parce que il y en
a pas beaucoup et il y en a pas il y en
a pas l etat fossiles surtout c'est
quand même est censé être une de la
paléontologie des vertébrés et à l'état
fossiles d un fils begnins ça court pas
les rues y en a je veux dire si vous
cherchez bien dans la littérature vous
en trouverez mais ils sont tous
relativement récent il nous renseigne
pas trop sur l'origine évolutive du
groupe quoi
donc mais par contre les eaux filiale et
mosasaures elle est là certes il ya eu
ils ont un bon registre fossile donc les
officiels et là certains y vivent encore
les mozart ils ne vivent plus là où
c'est marrant entre guillemets c'est que
en gros les eaux filiale et mozart
seraient tous les deux dérivés de la
certes il y un donc en fait on devrait
appeler tout ça encore une fois si on
prenait une vision phylogénétique du
truc aux fidjiens et mozart en fait ça
s'appellerait dès la sortie liens parce
que tout est dérivée de la certes il ya
en fait les les mosasaures ce sont des
warrants donc les warrants ce sont des
lézards et les serpents ils sont
probablement dérivés enfin c'est
probablement le groupe frère des
warrants du moins c'est ce que c'est ce
que semble indiquer les analyses
génétiques et si on rajoute les fossiles
dans le mix c'est peut-être même des
descendants directs des mozart ou de le
groupe frère des mots à tort parmi les
warrants bref
donc on va pas vraiment on va pas
vraiment trop comme je disais faux si on
veut rester concis vaut mieux esquiver
la phylogénie mais c'est très
intéressant à regarder en tout cas donc
ce qu'on va faire là c'est qu'on va
regarder les serpents on va regarder les
mozart dans le détail on va pas trop
regarder les là certes il y un tout
simplement parce que les la sortie liens
sont assez conformes à cette description
que je viens de vous donner des
squamates en général donc il n'y a pas
grand chose qui change
vous avez les iguanes par exemple qui
vont redevenir herbivores mais bon ça va
pas être la règle non plus vous avez et
qui du coup vont il ya certains groupes
qui vont perdre la morphologie pleuraux
d'hondt aussi par exemple
donc ça il va y avoir des petites
variations en fonction des familles mais
globalement les là certes il ya il reste
dans ce dans ce dans ce schéma on va
dire des squamates en général donc ceux
qui vont vraiment s'écarter du schéma
squamates c'est les mosasaures et les
aux fidjiens donc on va commencer par
les mosasaures les mosasaures qui ont un
très très bon registre fossile un peu
partout dans le monde y compris en
afrique et là par exemple vous avez une
reconstitution de delà d'une faune qui a
été retrouvé en angola du crétacé
du crétacé toit sont que quand on trouve
des mozart on sait qu'on parle du
crétacé puisque les modeuses azor se
trouvent principalement dans le crétacé
il y en a quelques-uns qui se retrouvent
éventuellement à la toute fin du
jurassique
mais les mosasaures c'est vraiment
typique du crétacé vous pouvez noter
d'ailleurs que sûr cette reconstitution
le mozart être hypo cercle si vous vous
rappelez du cours sur l'évolution des
poissons y poster que ça veut dire que
la colonne vertébrale part vers le bas
et ça ça vient du d'un fossile qui a été
découvert je crois que c'est au liban
qui est le seul mozart qui préserve des
tissus mous et qui montrait du coup que
là que partait vers le bas qui avaient
un petit lob de que uniquement tissus
mous qui partait vers le haut donc les
mosasaures c'est des descendants directs
des warrants et du coup comme ce sont
des warrants et bien ils ont des
articulations supplémentaires à
l'intérieur du crâne qu'on peut voir sur
le crâne donc ils ont déjà le joint plus
rocky enfin le joint stripped hostile
hic en haut du car est par contre le
carré et raie circulaire il est pâle on
est en forme de bâton il est circulaire
chez les mozart donc ça c'est un
caractère de mozart il ya un joint
stripped hostile hic vous avez un joint
médoquine éthiques et comme ce sont des
warrants il ya aussi une articulation à
l'avant du jus galles et en plus de
l'articulation à l'avant du jus galles
qu'on retrouve chez les warrants vous
avez une articulation sur la mandibule
ici entre langue eu l'air et le dentaire
donc vous avez un joint kinetic au
niveau de la mandibule donc tout ça tout
ça en fait ça permet à la bouche de
s'ouvrir encore plus grand et notamment
la conjugaison de l'articulation ici au
niveau de l'avant du jus galles et de
celle sur la mandibule permettent
d'écarter les mâchoires beaucoup plus
que si on se contentait de ce que le
crâne est normalement capables de faire
et en plus de ça vous avez à l'avant de
la demande de la mandibule les deux
mandibules ne sont pas attachées les
unes avec les autres
donc vous n'avez pas un menton comme on
en a chez nous les deux mandibules sont
libres de bouger indépendamment les unes
des autres et ça c'est pareil ça
augmente la capacité a engouffré
d'énormes morceaux d'énormes morceaux de
chair qui sont plus grosses que la
bouche ne serait s'il n'y avait pas
toutes ses articulations
donc ça déjà cédé caractère important
est aussi en lien avec la prédation le
développement des dents tecau dont tu
donc les dents tu es codante qui ont une
racine donc là on va très bien
d'ailleurs sur ce premier atout dont qui
viennent angola vous voyez on voit très
bien ici les aidants des dents avec une
racine
on a aussi beaucoup de mozart qui
viennent du crétacé d'afrique du nord
notamment du marocain les quelques m
donc c'est sûr ça ça se voit très bien
aussi si vous avez des dents chez vous
des quais mme kehm bon généralement
généralement je sais pas pourquoi mais
la racine et péter donc je ne sais pas
si c'est parce qu'il appelle
volontairement ou pas ce qu'ils
considèrent que c'est pas très joli ou
si c'est vraiment comme ça qu'il les
retrouve mais peut-être vous avez la
chance d'avoir une dent de de mozart des
ken ken avec sa racine donc c'est parce
que c'est dans ces colonnes
est ce que le mot hasard soit un
prédateur ou dur of ages bordure ofaj
c'est toujours prédateur mais là pour le
coup vous selon la taille vous pouvez
avoir des mozart qui mangeaient soit des
ammonites soit des tortues carrément
donc vous avez des deux types dentaire
chez les mozart des mozart qui était
plutôt tissus mous et des dinosaures qui
aimait bien craquer de la coquille
évidemment vous avez tous les caractères
associés à la vie aquatique donc les
bras qui sont plutôt court le
l'articulation du coude qui limitait au
niveau fonctionnel des doigts qui sont
aplaties et transformés en palettes
natatoire avec une augmentation de la
taille des phalanges
bref vous avez tout et puis la réduction
des membres postérieurs les mozart donc
il ya eu un article récent qui suggérait
que les mots zaz orpond dde
vous avez certainement vu passer la
vidéo sur la chaîne est ce que c'était
vraiment un oeuf de mozart c'est
toujours débattue disons que c'est la
meilleure hypothèse qu'on a et est ce
que est ce que ça veut dire qu'ils
étaient capables de retourner sur terre
peut-être pas forcément ce qu'ils
pouvaient pondre leurs oeufs directement
dans l'eau l'hypothèse qui est pour
l'instant reconnu c'est qu'ils pondent
leurs oeufs dans l'eau et que l'offre
devait éclore immédiatement avec le bébé
mozart
devait courir enfin nager directement
vers la surface pour pouvoir prendre sa
première goulée d'air
c'est l'hypothèse pour l'instant qu'on a
donc certainement les mozart ne pouvait
pas retourner sur terre non est le
deuxième groupe donc c'est les les aux
fidjiens donc les les serpents donc les
serpents qui en plus de tous les toutes
les articulations qu'on a déjà chez les
mozart donc l'articulation sur la
mâchoire l'articulation à l'avant du jus
galles vont développer 6
enfin trois autres points d'articulation
un à l'arrière du jus galles et deux à
l'avant du maxillaire plus des
articulations au niveau du terrygate
bref le crâne des serpents peut se
disloquer dans tous les sens voilà il ya
des tellement d'articulation
intracrânienne que le crâne des serpents
peut se disloquer dans tous les sens et
c'est pour ça qu'ils arrivent à avaler
c'est comme ça qu'ils arrivent à avaler
à peu près ce qu'ils veulent de la
taille quelle que soit la taille et ça
se reflète sur la morphologie du crâne
parce que si vous regardez le crâne d'un
reptile primitif et que vous le comparez
un crâne de serpents tous les os en
verre que vous voyez là ont été perdus
chez les serpents donc tout ça ça allège
le crâne ça enlève des articulations ça
permet de mieux disloqué le la bestiole
donc le seul os qui est vraiment solide
et solidement attaché aux autres chez
les serpents c'est le pari et al parce
qu'il contient la boîte crânienne
parce qu'il contient le cerveau donc
c'est pour empêcher en fait le pariétal
recouvre complètement le cerveau en
ferme complètement le cerveau et le
protège en fait quand le serpent a valu
une grosse propre parce que sinon le
cerveau et à écraser
vous imaginez que si enfin faut savoir
que chez les reptiles la boîte crânienne
est généralement cartilagineuse donc à
part sur le dessus parce que c'est la
phase exposées à l'extérieur le dessous
c'est cartilagineux donc si c'était
cartilagineux chez les serpents bas vous
imaginez bien que en avalant une grosse
proie
cela écraserait complètement le cerveau
on risquerait des dommages assez assez
irréparable donc chez les serpents
le problème est résolu en aussi fiant
totalement la boîte crânienne grâce aux
pariétal le pariétal
en cercle entre encerclent complètement
la boîte crânienne et protège le cerveau
donc ça c'est et puis du coup du fait
qu'il ya plein de choses qui sont perdus
et qui a plein de l'articulation partout
là le le crâne est à peine 10 abside les
fausses d'iab sites sont complètement
perdus vous pouvez regarder le ces
crânes de serpents je vous mets au défi
de trouver le les fausses dit abside
elles sont plus vraiment là par contre
vous voyez toujours le carré qui est
très très long comme chez les hommes
chez les squamates donc il ya pas trop
de doutes sur le fait que ce sont des
squamates et vous avez toujours le joint
stripped au style it qui est là le joint
médoquine éthique qui est directement
héritée des squamates et vous avez les
dents alors c'est intéressant les dents
parce qu'il ya des dents qui sont
pleuraux d'hondt comme chez les
squamates et il ya des dents qui sont
tes codon enfin on dit pseudo tu es
codante et ce sont les les crocs donc
les grand crohot des des serpents
venimeux notamment ont une honte une
racine et ça du coup ça pourrait relier
les serpents home aux açores en plus des
articulations du fait que certaines
articulations sont partagés avec les
mosasaures ça pourrait aussi relier les
serpents au mozart après vous avez le
grand débat sur les serpents sont lille
d'origine aquatique ou d'origine
terrestre
donc pourquoi est ce qu'ils ont perdu
leur leurs membres donc on sait que les
on sait que les que les espèces qui
évolue en milieu aquatique ont tendance
à avoir leur leurs membres qui se
réduisent donc leurs bras et leurs
jambes qui se réduisent
on sait aussi que certaines espèces qui
évoluent et deviennent fouisseuses
notamment les cécilien chez les
amphibiens et les ans fils bnia chez les
squamates ont aussi tendance à perdre
leurs membres donc en fait il rampe à
l'intérieur de leurs de leur galerie
et puis le corps et de la forme de la
galerie donc ça tombe bien quoi donc ça
c'est et c'est encore un débat
aujourd'hui à savoir comment les
serpents ont réellement perdu leurs
membres on sait pas vraiment encore et
encore récemment ont favorisé plutôt
l'hypothèse d'une origine d'une origine
parmi des espèces fouisseuses notamment
par des caractères de l'oreille parce
que
oreille interne de certains serpents
très ancien est plutôt adaptée à
l'audition des basses fréquences donc
des ondes sismiques dans le sol mais bon
tout ça c'est essayer très très débattue
c'est très débattue donc et il ya une
origine possible du coup parmi les
mosasaures si on suit l'hypothèse d'une
origine aquatique des serpents voilà
c'est surtout là où je voulais en venir
c'est qu'il ya peut-être un lien entre
serpent et mozart aussi les serpents
perdre le père de le foramen pinéale
donc c'est ce que vous voyez là le
foramen pinéale est ici et là il est
perdu ce qui semblerait logique si leurs
ancêtres et fo is her puisque une espèce
qui vit sous terre n'a pas besoin
d'avoir plus dieu qu'elle en a déjà un
donc et puis évidemment les comme je
disais les traits les plus l'être le
trait le plus important chez les
serpents c'est la longueur du corps donc
la multiplication du nombre de vertèbres
qui est en lien aussi avec la perte des
membres donc on a généralement plus de
120 vertèbres chez les serpents et les
vertèbres ont ce qu'on appelle une
double articulation
ils ont une articulation qui s'appelle
le zygo ce fun et qui s'articule aux
îles entre hommes et ils ont des
articulations que qui sont les
articulations classique qu'on appelle
les apps les igg apophyses donc très
postiga beaufils donc il ya un double
jeu d'articulation entre les vertèbres
chez les serpents encore que ce double
jeu d'articulation des vertèbres soit
pas si rare que ça puisque l'on
rencontre aussi chez les dinosaures chez
les dinosaures théropodes et on le
rencontre aussi par exemple chez les
pareil azor donc c'est pas non plus si
typique que ça des serpents et puis
niveau registre fossile on parle
beaucoup de titanoboa mais l'afrique n'a
pas à rougir puisque on avait aussi j
vente office qui vivait en egypte et qui
a et qui est qu'ici on le compare un
python de 5 à 7 mètres de long a quand
même des vertèbres qui suggère un animal
bien costaud voilà donc il n'ya pas il
n'y a pas de quoi rougir en afrique on a
aussi des gros serpent d'abord est un
des plus vieux serpents bien que ce soit
très très très très contestée mais ça
pourrait être un des plus vieux serpents
c'est tétrapodes office donc qui comme
son nom l'indiqué est un serpent à
quatre pattes dont quatre pattes qui
sont très très bien visible sur le
fossile
le prologue alors il a aussi une double
articulation des vertèbres mais comme je
viens de vous le dire c'est pas si rare
que ça une double articulation des
vertèbres sais pas si typique que ça des
serpents et est le truc c'est que le
crâne ne ressemble pas du tout à celui
d'un serpent le crâne est assez massif
en fait donc c'est possiblement un autre
type de l'epide aux orres qui aurait
évolué de façon convergente vers un type
serpentiforme une morphologie
serpentiforme ce qui est déjà arrivé
plein de fois vous pensez aux horvais
par exemple ou bien aux en fils begnins
voilà c'est pas si rare que ça
finalement
d'ailleurs je précise les eaux revêt
sont bien des lézards se sont ni des
serpents ni des amphis se baignant
puisque j'en parle
voilà un autre candidat possible au plus
vieux fossile de serpent bas ce sont une
c'est une série d'empreintes qu'on a
retrouvé en afrique du sud dans le
jurassique donc là c'est vraiment très
très vieux début du jurassique
je vous avais expliqué il ya quelques
temps enfin il ya la vidéo précédente
au début du jurassique on avait un
désert en afrique du sud et qu'il y
avait des dunes et des dunes qui était
fossilisés réellement et la danse le
sable de ces dunes fossilisés du début
du jurassique
on trouve des traces ici qui sont
parallèles et qui correspondent à un
animal qui s'est déplacé exactement de
la même manière qu'un serpent se déplace
dans le sable aujourd'hui donc voyez ces
traces obliqué parallèle exactement
comme ce qu'on voit là ça veut pas
forcément dire que c'est un serpent qui
les a faits mais comme aujourd'hui ça
peut être n'importe quel animal
serpentiforme on est d'accord mais comme
aujourd'hui il ya que les serpents les
vrais serpents parmi tous les animaux
serpentiforme qui existent aujourd'hui
il ya que les vrais serpents qui font ça
bon c'est peut-être parce que les autres
vivent pas forcément dans le désert mais
bon voilà la question est dans l'air on
saura probablement jamais si c'est des
vrais serpents qui ont fait ça mais en
tout cas c'est peut-être la plus vieille
traces de serpent fossile du monde
des heurts et abside donc les les
animaux qui ont un crâne rient abside
parmi lesquels on va trouver les
ichthyosaures et les plésiosaures donc
essentiellement des reptiles marins du
mésozoïque mozart exclu puisque on vient
de voir ce sont des sondés squamates
donc là on est à l'extérieur des squames
at on vient de ressortir des squames
atteint que les choses soient claires
voilà donc on est à l'extérieur des
squames a t on va voir les oreilles
abside donc ces animaux qui ont une
fausse temporal en fout en position
supérieure uniquement donc c'est comme
un crâne dioxine mais la fausse temporal
inférieur a été perdu alors comment
cette fausse temporal inférieur a été
perdu peut-être qu'elle s'est tout
simplement ouverte comme celle et comme
chez les squames hat et qu'après on fait
les eaux ont repoussé et se sont rejoint
donc le quadra tôt jules galles dont on
a parlé tout à l'heure qui relie le
carré au jus galles était séparé du jeu
égal mais après ces eaux ont repoussé se
sont rejoint pour fermer la fosse donc
bon c'est une hypothèse on sait pas
exactement comment ça s'est produit pour
être tout à fait honnête et on sait pas
non plus exactement encore en quoi ce
serait un avantage en fait de perdre une
fausse temporal donc bon ben c'est pas
la peine de me poser la question en
commentaire je n'ai aucune idée de
pourquoi d'ailleurs la plupart du temps
vous allez me demander pourquoi pourquoi
ces choses se passent et je vous
répondrai que j'en sais rien parce que
il ya beaucoup de choses qu'on ne sait
pas et il ya beaucoup de choses que je
ne sais pas voilà enfin dans l'est dans
la grande quantité de choses que je ne
sais pas il ya des choses pour
lesquelles je peux dire qu'on ne sait
pas voilà donc que les mêmes les
spécialistes les plus renommées en la
matière ne savent pas donc les reptiles
marins du mésozoïque donc ils vont avoir
encore une fois la même série
d'adaptations
la vie marine que l'on voit chez les
mozart donc multiplication du nombre de
phalanges très souvent parfois même
multiplication du nombre de doigts
transformation des mains en palettes
natatoire avec ce que ça implique
d'aplatissement des phalanges et de de
perte de mobilité du coude et du genou
on va avoir généralement bas alors on va
avoir chez les ecchymoses or une queue
hypo cercle qui va se développer
par contre chez les plésiosaures on va
pas avoir de que là que va se réduire
donc là que va pas forcément suivre
l'évolution typique qu'on a vu chez les
mosasaures par contre sur le crâne
on va avoir les narines qui vont se
rétracter alors pourquoi les narines se
rétracte c'est comme les vents des
cétacés c'est plus facile de respirer à
la surface quand on a les narines vers
l'arrière que quand on les narines au
bout du museau
donc c'est un peu ça va un peu me mais
les vents des cétacés et on va avoir une
dentition généralement fortement aux
maux dont tu fait dedans qui sont un peu
en forme de groupes de hans ont en fait
donc ça se sait aussi un caractère
conquis et générale à tous les animaux
tous les tétrapodes qu'il s'adapte à la
vie aquatique même les mammifères donc
si vous pensez aux dauphins par exemple
redéveloppe une dentition au mode honte
en s'adaptant à la vie aquatique donc
vous pouvez aller voir ma vidéo sur
l'évolution des cétacés si vous
souhaitez en savoir plus ce qu'on va
avoir aussi comme chez les mosasaures
c'est le l'attachement du sacrum qui va
devenir très très faible donc évidemment
le canton vie sur terre on a besoin d'un
sacré homme solide mais quand on vit
dans l'eau la tâche de des vertèbres
avec la ceinture pelvienne devient
beaucoup plus faible parce que toute
façon elle a plus besoin d'être très
solide tout simplement donc ça sert à
rien de gâcher de l'énergie à faire ça
les côtes deviennent très épaisse est
très lourde
encore une fois pour plaquer l'animal
pour entraîner l'animal vers le fond
puisque la flottabilité d'un tétrapodes
est généralement égales
enfin est généralement inférieure à
celle de l'eau donc sa flotte
donc là donc les tétrapodes y flotte
spontanément donc il faut des côtes
relativement lourde qui vont entraîner
l'animal vers le fond et on va avoir des
vertèbres qui vont être de forme
discoïde donc la forme qu'on appelle en
ficelle donc qui et qui mime en fait les
vertèbres d'un requin ou d'un poisson si
vous regardez les vertèbres d'un poisson
ici vous voyez qu elles sont très
similaires à celles d'anne ichthyosaures
ici donc parce qu'elles sont en ficelle
et si vous prenez les vertèbres d'un
dauphin c'est pareil pourquoi pourquoi
cette forme si simple de vertèbres
c'est en partie parce qu'une fois de
plus il ya pas besoin de soutien sur
terre donc si on n'a pas besoin de
soutien sur terre il n'y a pas besoin
d'avoir des vertèbres qui s'articulent
les unes aux autres et qui permettent de
soutenir le poids et qui sont hyper
fortement attachés on peut juste se
permettre d'avoir des vertèbres attaché
de façon assez finalement assez souple
et d'ailleurs la souplesse de la colonne
vertébrale est aussi un facteur
déterminant que quand il s'agit là j'ai
évidemment faut pouvoir articuler faut
pouvoir agiter la queue notamment chez
les équipes aux ors et chez les dauphins
faut pouvoir agiter la queue donc faut
aussi une certaine flexibilité de la
colonne vertébrale qui n'est pas permise
si on a une colonne vertébrale super
rigide pour soutenir le poids du corps
qui est pas forcément permis on va dire
donc donc cédé caractère qu'on retrouve
généralement chez toutes les espèces
adaptées au milieu aquatique pas
seulement chez les ch et les ori abside
on les retrouve aussi chez les
mosasaures chez les mozart on a aussi
une attache une attache du sacrum qui
est très faible et on retrouve aussi ça
chez les dauphins chez les dauphins il
ya même plus de bassins et d'ailleurs
donc le premier groupe de riz apside ce
sont les ichthyosaures donc les
ichthyosaures qui sont les reptiles
marins qui ressemble plus à des dauphins
ils ont un petit aileron dorsal comme
les dauphins ils ont ils ont un long
museau comme les dauphins avec des
narines qui sont rétractés fortement
vers l'arrière comme les vents des
dauphins ils ont des dents qui ressemble
beaucoup à celle de dauphin à 7
à cette distinction près que les que
vous voyez elles sont alignés dans une
gouttière donc on n'a pas des dents qui
sont éco don't need aidants qui sont
accros dont en fait il ya une gouttière
dans laquelle toutes les dents sont
enchâssés donc qu'il ya quand même une
racine mais c'est pas exactement la
condition tecau donc ça c'est très
typique des ichtyosaures est ce que
c'est ce qui permet d'identifier un
ichtyosaure même si vous trouvez un
petit morceau comme ça si vous trouvez
un petit morceau comme ça vous avez
toutes les dents aligné dans la même
gouttière vous êtes sûr que vous venez
de trouver un morceau dicter aux orres
donc vous pouvez fêter ça bon déjà vous
avez trouvé de l'os trouvé de l'os c'est
déjà un bel accomplissement en soi mais
en plus pouvoir l'identifier c'est
encore mieux et là pour le coup ça
s'identifie très très bien on a aussi
généralement chez les ichthyosaures de
très grands yeux et qui ont à un anneau
sclérotique très développée notamment
chez ophthalmosaurus par exemple qu'ils
pouvaient qui on le pense un protégé
l'oeil quand il quand il plonge est
entré en profondeur tout en permettant
de voir dans le noir à très hautes
profondeur parce que le gros oeil
pouvait capter plus de lumière
généralement chez les ichthyosaures
alors chez les ichthyosaures les plus
dérivés la ceinture pelvienne et les
pattes arrières sont très très réduite
mais si vous prenez les ichtyosaures
tous les premiers et que tu oses or
comme shonisaurus et d'autres dix petits
aux ors du trias vous allez avoir des
grosses pattes arrière ils vont plus
ressembler à des mozart mais ils ont
déjà le rostre ils ont déjà d'autres
caractères qui les attachent aux autres
ichtyosaures elle a la queue comme je le
disais type au cercle
c'est ce qui a été montré par les très
très beau et qui use or qu'on a
découvert en allemagne à old madden et
il ya une robe quand même supérieur qui
fait ressembler la queue à celle d'un
requin d'ailleurs la morphologie fait
beaucoup penser à celle des dauphins
sauf la queue qui ressemble à celle d'un
requin et ça c'est c'est tout à fait
logique en fait c'est parce que les
dauphins sont descendants de mammifères
et les mammifères quand il court si vous
regardez un chien courir le chien il va
il va plier son corps de haut en bas
d'avant en arrière alors que le lézard
alors que les ichthyosaures qui sont
descendants de reptiles de reptiles lépi
de zorro morph le ils sont descendants
de lézards de trucs qui ressemblaient à
des lézards du moins et qui devait
secouer leur camp fin qu'il devait
bouger leur corps de gauche à droite
quand il courait donc donc en fait le
l'articulation des vertèbres pour un
ichtyosaure était déjà prête à bouger de
gauche à droite alors que l'articulation
des vertèbres pour un dauphin était déjà
prête à bouger dirt en bas et ça c'est
dû à la position des membres chez leurs
ancêtres en fait celle est l'ancêtre des
dauphins les membres étaient sous le
corps donc c'est plus facile de courir
en plus en priant le corps comme un
accordéon
alors que chez les alors que celle et
lépide aux orres l'ancêtre des lipides
aux oraux morph dont son descendant les
ichthyosaures on avait plutôt à l'animal
qui devait courir comme un lézard sur un
mur c'est à dire en se dandinant de
gauche à droite
donc c'est c'est marrant en fait de voir
qu'il ya eu convergence évolutive mais
avec toujours une signature de l'origine
phylogénétique de l'animal voilà donc
qui fait que la convergence est pas
parfaite
voilà est donc en afrique on est je vais
pas beaucoup parlé des ichtyosaures
enfin je vais pas en parler plus que ça
on a beaucoup dit ti aux or en france on
a trouvé beaucoup beaucoup notamment
dans là tout ce qui est mare noire du
train du jurassique inférieur
si vous habitez dans le sud de la france
vous en avez déjà certainement vu les
mare noire des causses notamment donc on
a beaucoup dit que tu oses or en france
on a beaucoup dit qu'ils osent en europe
mais en afrique on en a pas il ya zéro
ichthyosaures le sol ichthyosaures kia
ca compte presque pas pour l'afrique
parce qu'on trouve à madagascar donc
c'est pas tellement l'afrique
continentale
disons que bon géologiquement ça reste
l'afrique
et puis c'est un peu alors c'est moi
pareil pour les plésiosaures les
plésiosaures on en a quand même un peu
plus puisque les plésiosaures on en
trouve jusque dans le crétacé et dans le
crétacé d'angola notamment on trouve de
beaux ichthyosaures donc comme cardio
corax
par exemple et on trouve non seulement
des plésiosaures idées mais aussi des
plis au zoo rider donc chez les
plésiosaures il ya deux types de
familles mais on va on va en arriver là
d'abord les plésiosaures en général les
plésiosaures ya donc les plésiosaures ya
contrairement aux et qui ose or ils ont
à craindre plutôt plat avec une crête
sagittale une crête sagittale pourquoi
parce que la fosse temporal est très
très étendue est tellement étendu en
fait que les deux fosses temporal se
joignent au milieu du crâne et compresse
la boîte crânienne en une crête
sagittale donc c'est pour ça vous avez
une clé de sagittale si vous n'y
connaissez rien en anatomie c'est très
très difficile de faire la différence
entre la fosse temporal d' un
plésiosaure et la fosse temporal d'un
thé rapide même si c'est pas la même
parce que l'est celle été rapide c'est
la fausse temporal inférieur et chez les
plier plésiosaures c'est la fausse
temporal supérieur mais comme les deux
sont tellement étendu que elles
finissent par se toucher au milieu en
formant une crête sagittale on n'arrive
même plus à savoir s'il s'agit du dessus
de crâne ou sur le côté du crâne donc
c'est très très difficile de faire la
différence entre les deux ce qui va vous
permettre de faire la différence ça va
être de regarder le condyle occipital en
fait donc il faut regarder
l'articulation du crâne avec les
vertèbres une crête sagittale
globalement celle été rapide on n'en
trouve pas ailleurs que chez les terros
et fall et chez les signaux dont tu es
chez les terreaux céphalées les signaux
sont en fait le le conduit occipital n'a
pas la même n'a pas cette forme en boule
convexe qu'on va trouver chez les soro
psid et notamment chez les plus de 12
heures par exemple donc celle été rossés
fall ça va être en forme il va être un
peu en forme de banane ou enfin le
candidat occipital va être en forme de
banane ou en forme de derain de haricots
si vous voulez et chez les sino dont il
est divisé en deux comme chez les
mammifères donc il n'y a aucune erreur à
faire de ce côté là donc si vous avez
une crête sagittale et que vous n'êtes
pas sûr de ce que vous êtes en train de
regarder faut regarder le candide
occipital s'il est tout rond
c'est un plésiosaure s'il est pas tout
rond c'est un terreau cefalù ainsi 90
après faut voir s'il est en forme de
haricot enfin ou alors carrément divisé
en deux
mais c'est pointu là ça devient un peu
pointu on va c'est une digression un peu
longue
ce qui va aussi caractérisé les
plésiosaures ça va être l'extrême
extension de leur de leur ceinture
pelvienne et de leur ceinture scapulaire
notamment les eaux qui s'appelle le
pubis donc à l'avant de la ceinture
pelvienne et le corail coheed ici en
dessous de la ceinture scapulaire
donc on a des grosses plaques en fait
donc il ya un nombre limité de gastes
rallye il ya un nombre limité de gastes
rallye qui sont toujours pas qui est aux
tic mai mais ils sont essentiellement
replacé par la plaque corac aux idées la
plaque pubienne donc c'est ce que vous
voyez là chez cardio corax par exemple
évidemment les encore une fois les
palettes natatoire sont très très plate
ce que vous pouvez voir ici une fois de
plus là c'est une palette natatoire donc
c'est les palettes natatoire sont très
plate très très développé en fait
puisqu'il s'agit d'animaux qui ne
nageait pas avec la force de la queue
mais qui nageait avec la force de leurs
pattes comme les comme les tortues donc
ils ont des très très longue palette
natatoire la poly phalange y est très
très développée donc la poly phalange
hisser le phénomène de multiplication du
nombre de phalanges dans les doigts elle
est très très prononcé on la retrouve
aussi de façon plus modérée chez les
ichthyosaures vous voyez que chez les
ichthyosaures les phalanges elles sont
quand même bien ronde est plutôt courte
là on a des phalanges qui sont plutôt
allongé est très très très très
nombreuses chez les ch et les
plésiosaures et ça ça compense parce
qu'il n'ya pas de queue pour les
propulser en fait la queue est très très
courte et enfin les plésiosaures en
général ont plutôt un coût relativement
l'eau et mais on va voir que ça varie en
fonction des deux familles et ils sont
présents jusqu au crétacé contrairement
aux ichthyosaures qui s'éteignent au
vert le au début du crétacé en fait les
plésiosaures eux ils vont survivre
jusqu'à la fin du crétacé jusqu'à
l'extension l'extinction crétacé
paléogène et les plésiosaures donc on
les divise en deux familles les
plésiosaures idées et les plis autorités
etc plésiosaures idc puis aux oreilles
des on les distingue surtout par la
longueur de leurs
de leurs coûts les plésiosaures ont un
coût très très long et une toute petite
tête les pliosaure ou un coût
relativement court comparé aux
plésiosaures 28 werther ça fait quand
même beaucoup mais ils ont un coût
relativement court et ils ont une grosse
tête
voilà donc là on a plutôt des à deux
stratégies de chasse qui devait être
différente alors peut-être plus en
embûches en embuscade chez les
plésiosaures et peut-être chez les
plésiosaures idée est peut-être plus un
chasseur actif avec les pliosaure idée
mais bon là je m'avance peut être un peu
trop en tout cas en afrique donc on a
des vrais plésiosaures comme zara face
aux russes qui est un et l'asmo au rider
en témoigne sa trés trés sont très très
très très long cou très typique des
hells motorisés la longueur du cou est
assez incroyable chez zara face aux
russes et on a déplié pliosaure idée le
seul pliosaure d'afrique d'ailleurs qui
l époque les innus et qui vient
d'afrique du sud donc et qui a une très
grosse tête
il ya plein d'autres rehab sites dont
j'aurais pu parler comme par exemple les
plaques au doute qui sont qui étaient
des gros animaux du rov âge dont
certains pas tous mais certains ont
évolué une carapace qui ressemble
beaucoup à celle des tortues mais aucun
lien de parenté et j'aurais pu parler
des notes aux orres aussi j'aurais pu
parler donc les notes aux orres qui
ressemble beaucoup d'ailleurs au prix
ozo rider j'aurais pu parler des détails
ni ce trophée idée qui ressemble plus au
plésiosaures mais qui à la différence
près que d'une part ils sont plutôt
relié aux archosaures mais qu' ils sont
pas vraiment rihab side du coup mais
surtout que leur coût et est long mais
il est fait de très très peu de
vertèbres donc c'est des vertèbres qui
sont très très longue donc tanis trophée
juge par exemple qu'on a retrouvé en
italie
donc pas loin de la france fait partie
de ce groupe là donc j'aurais pu parler
de ces trois groupes là mais c'est des
groupes qui n'existe que au trias et
d'ailleurs même pas tout le trias
d'ailleurs donc c'est des groupes qui se
sont apparus au trias uniquement et
qu'on ne trouve que dans l'hémisphère
nord
donc une fois de plus c'est les groupes
qui n'ont aucun registre fossile en
afrique donc c'est pour ça que j'en
parle pas dans mon cours sachez qu'ils
existent et qu'on en trouve par chez
nous ce qui nous amène finalement au
groupe que vous attendez tous le point
culminant de ceux de c2c cours de cette
série de court les archosaures puisqu'on
va enfin pouvoir attaquer les dinosaures
donc on verra ça la prochaine fois les
archosaures parce que c'est un gros gros
morceau et qu'il va bien falloir une
bonne grosseur poutou pour tout couvrir
donc je vous dis à la prochaine fois où
on parlera des archosaures salut